coming up on the drop zone cap you do
anything funny Saturday night well all
the guys in my barbershop quartet are
dead so no not really you know if you
ask Kristen out from Statistics you'd
probably say yes that's why don't ask
too shy or too scared too busy
is he wearing a parachute no he wasn't
join shield to protect people captain to
build a better world sometimes means
tearing the old one down that makes
enemies
are you ready for the world to see you
as you really are
look out the window you know how the
game works
disorder war
all it takes is one step
we will neutralize a lot of threats
before they even happen
I thought the punishment usually came
after the crime shield takes the world
as it is not as we'd like it to be this
isn't freedom this is fear
you need to keep both eyes open before
we get started does anyone want to get
out
your work has been a gift to mankind
you've shaped the century
I need you to do it one more time
yeah it's time
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Marvel
just posted the trailer for Captain
America the Winter Soldier so I thought
I'd do a breakdown on the trailer and
some of the most important things about
the movie don't worry I'll give it a big
spoiler warning before spoilers so a
couple big things from the trailer we
noticed two main things he wears two
different uniforms there's been a couple
teasers over the last couple days he has
the classic Captain American uniform and
the more modern one that he's wearing in
this scene it's just blue with the star
on it we say Frank Grillo who's Blanc
crossbones in the movie and we see the
Winter Soldier played by Bucky Barnes of
course so the Winter Soldier is actually
going to dovetail with the agents of
shield storyline it's gonna explain what
shields been up to since the Avengers
has been over it's about a two-year time
gap between the Avengers and this movie
but the movie is mostly about Captain
America learning to deal with the modern
world that is where the government tends
to mistreat its citizens in the trailer
it's kind of implied that shield is
taking action against other forces and
people before they actually do things so
it's getting very heavy-handed and
Captain America has a big problem with
this let's talk about a few spoilers now
so spoiler warning if you remember from
Avengers they talked about phase 2
weaponry basically shield is building an
arsenal of weapons obviously you see in
the trailer they're basically building
an armada of ships and it looks like
it's happening all below Washington DC
so I think that's kind of funny but the
main antagonist of the film is not the
Winter Soldier it's actually Robert
Redford's character he's basically the
one that's commandeering all these
assets and having shield strike all
these targets prematurely but the
Captain America tale is typically mostly
about one man's fight to make a
difference so obviously that's why you
see Captain America bashing stuff and
ships crashing into the ground so
clearly he's going to have some sort of
giant epic hero moment where he crashes
that giant ship but I'm really excited
to see Robert Redford in the franchise
he's a great actor and Frank Grillo is
amazing too if you haven't seen warrior
yet you should go watch that it also
looks like Nick Fury is seriously
injured during one of these preemptive
strikes but I'm guessing that Captain
America basically rebels against Robert
Redford and that's why they try to take
him down in that elevator scene he
basically gets on the wrong side of
shield and tries to take down Robert
Redford well let me know what your
thoughts on the trailer are it's really
exciting it was about two and a half
minutes so it technically is a full
trailer but they might release another
one in a couple months so I'm excited to
see some more footage from the film
Anthony Mackie should be a lot of fun as
the Falcon he is hilarious if you've
seen any of his interviews he is
ridiculous he did love
Comic Con interviews where he was
basically doing an impression of Will
Smith the whole time is really funny
I'll be doing tons more Captain America
and Marvel videos I also do shield
videos every week be sure to subscribe
I'm also gonna be posting my Thor the
dark world review in a couple days
you can actually click here to watch the
full Marvel panel from Comic Con they
actually have the Winter Soldier panel
in that too so that's inside that video
and you can click here to watch all my
other Marvel videos thank you so much
for watching you guys are amazing high
five see you tomorrow
you